The Castro's comprehensive secondary
school was a buzz with excitement this
past Friday as students, teachers, and
officials gathered to celebrate World
Home Economics Day 2025 under the theme
tackling over consumption. The event
hosted by the school's vocational
department placed a spotlight on food
security, sustainable agricultural
practices, and the role of responsible
consumption in public health. This
year's observance took on added
significance with the presence of the
Ministry of Agriculture, signaling the
start of a promising partnership aimed
at integrating agra food systems
development and education into the
curriculum. Acting Deputy Permanent
Secretary in the Ministry of
Agriculture, Dr. Randall Esnard
delivered a compelling address
underscoring the importance of local
food production and youth engagement in
agriculture. This is why today's event
is so important. It brings awareness of
these issues and highlights solutions
through education and sustainable
practices. The Ministry of Agriculture
is committed to ensuring that food and
nutrition security and sustainable
agriculture are not just national
priorities but also
uh accessible and practical for our
citizens.
We have several initiatives that have
been implemented to encourage
responsible food consumption and promote
locally grown produce.
These include the youth in agriculture
uh the youth agri entrepreneurial
entrepreneurship program sorry uh the
year program which I'm pretty sure that
some of you guys have heard about uh in
one form or another which is designed to
empower young persons like yourselves to
explore careers in agriculture food
production and agra business. The day's
activities saw students participating in
interactive sessions, food preparation
demonstrations, and exhibitions
showcasing innovative ways to reduce
waste and incorporate more locally grown
produce into their diets. The Ministry
of Agricultures educational booth
featured live demonstrations of
sustainable farming techniques,
composting, and the benefits of organic
food production. Head of the vocational
department, Priscilla Kodra, in
emphasizing the importance of equipping
students with both theoretical knowledge
and practical skills that align with
national priorities says she stands
ready to partner with allied
institutions and relevant authorities to
help bring about a greater awareness and
appreciation for the benefits of local a
food offerings among her students. It's
a step in the right direction. This is
the kind of thing we want to be doing
with our students. What we did today,
educating them because they are the ones
who will cater for us later and cater
for themselves and we are supposed to
guide them. So tackling over consumption
help us help our students open their
eyes. I was even surprised that even the
art students some of the creations that
they came up with in showing how to take
care of of over consumption not just
with food but how to manage the
waste you know so it definitely started
the students
thinking you know about our future and
how they are eating
because look at our situation with the
NCDS the non-communicable diseases
diseases. These are seriously on the
rise in St. Lucia and to me we need to
do much more. We need to have to me
weekly activities, monthly activities to
address those issues. The event also
tied into St. Lucia's independence
theme, Duva Assam, health and well-being
for a prosperous nation. Reinforcing the
message that food security is integral
to national development with discussions
on school gardening projects and
upcoming agricultural training
initiatives. The foundation was laid for
a continued relationship between
Castra's comprehensive secondary school
and the Ministry of Agriculture. From
the communications unit of the Ministry
of Agriculture, this is Amanda FC Clark
reporting.